ariella sponsors the Oscars on Sky the
home of red carpet fashion
hello you're watching a special edition
of entertainment week we're in LA on the
biggest weekend in the movie calendar
the Oscars coming up on this show will
be discussing all the nominees with our
film critics and giving our tips and
predictions the director of selma ava
duvernay gives her opinion on the
controversy surrounding the movies snubs
we hear from some of the brits hoping
for success and we'll be giving you a
tour of the hottest spot in hollywood
the oscars red carpet welcome to an
entertainment week special from the
rooftop of the andaz hotel in Los
Angeles the city where countless
hopefuls come to make their dreams of
stardom come true this weekend
tinseltown is celebrating those who've
made it the nominees for this year's
87th Academy Awards in a moment we'll be
giving our verdict but first let's have
a look at the first four movies up for
Best Picture if you reverse time and the
University getting smaller all right
what if I reverse the process all the
way back to see what happens at the
beginning of time itself mine back the
touch why about the clock it's the
greatest encryption device in history
the Germans use it for all major
communications everyone thinks enigma is
unbreakable if you cry and we'll know
for sure
dripless your Gustave H i bequeath
painting known as boy with Apple ah what
Oh Gustave H I'm afraid that's me done
well I'm now joined by our film critics
democratic and la weekly's amy nicholson
lovely sebo Joe starting with you the
theory of everything I absolutely up
this film it's also our best chance of
getting an Oscar is knit with Eddie
Redmayne yeah meanie he's got the
momentum hasn't he got the Golden Globe
the BAFTA the Screen Actors Guild as
well and they should always get it right
so the mountains there but i think we
think you know because he's a Brit that
he's got it locked in by very good he's
very good it's a beautiful thing very
good but but two is good i think because
he's a Briton i think a lot of american
audiences are unfamiliar with him they
might think oh this young katie is a
whippersnapper he'll get a bunch more
chances so I would not be surprised to
see Michael Keaton sneak it we're racing
patio main definitely Eddie Redmayne
okay the imitation game Amy and this has
got eight nominations so it's right up
there at the top of the nominations but
it seems to have lost momentum despite
the fact that Harvey Weinstein has been
mounting the most formidable campaign
hasn't it it's true i mean i feel like
in a way those two biotics about british
people are sort of cancelling each other
out you know it's a little bit of biopic
fatigue I have a lot of problems with
the imitation game I don't think it's
necessarily a good enough film to really
even be up on this list it will cont
reverse I know sorry every Sunday
afternoon till the TV movie feel I think
there's there's truth in that I don't
think they make Island turning into a
real person at all honestly like they
keep them just very robotic in a degree
I think you completely forget as
Benedict Cumberbatch I mean everything
wonderful before I don't think you're
able to forget his military thing that
has ever done and don't forget keira
knightley Keira Knightley's also worked
for an Oscar for this I don't think
she's got any time she's almost the best
thing in the film keira knightley it's a
wonderful before was the best thing in
the first she's been overshadowed by
combat shall is it it's true and her
phone begin again was overshadowed here
this summer and I think she's just
wonderful in that so keira knightley has
had a shocker but Benedict Cumberbatch
probably won't get the Oscar anyway
anyway on to whiplash now Joe this is
your absolute favorite film well if I
could give out every Oscar to whiplash I
would I mean I think it's a wonderful
film it's exhilarating it's a
rollercoaster ride you kind of can't
stop watching it JK Simmons has got Best
Supporting Actor tied up i think maybe
not in the back
yeah i would give it best picture I mean
I think there's not a single film this
year that sort of jolted you and sort of
how'd you back in your chair and you
kind of thrilled you like that Amy I
agree it's such a funny little weird
film I mean I saw opening night at
Sundance and I would have never guessed
then that it would make it this far at
all I've never thought it would be an
awards film at all but it's one of those
great little tidy strange 70s guitars on
it yeah exactly and I'm a huge fan of
miles teller the lead who i think has
been pretty overshadowed in a whole
conversation he's extraordinary single
scene isn't a which is sensational for
such a young actor and he's so powerful
is I think the thing of whiplash not
sure it has a longevity that bats
boyhood has in 10 years time will you
watch whiplash and say this is a
fantastic film but for now it just is
caught people up isn't it amazing I
think it almost so funny and so mean
it's hard for them to like that kind of
movie you know they don't really reward
movies with a little bit of black humor
like that but it reminds me of rocky in
many respects it's kind of a boxing
movie a a sports moving you know rocky
came up on won best picture in the 70s
this small thing but it's not going to
get better i can guarantee i just want
to graph finally for now at the grand
budapest hotel now this leads the
nominations they meet with nine is wes
anderson's highly stylized ville it's
not for everyone and it's really really
surprised i think most people that it's
got so many nominations and it did very
well at the BAFTAs it's true this is
actually the film i secretly wish would
win no I've never been a huge Wes
Anderson Finn I went to the grand
budapest hotel dreading it because I
always thought his films were really
precious all about the wallpaper not
about the characters and suddenly this
film his whole career made sense to me
because he he sets his whole beautiful
world in this hotel right before world
war two destroys everything and all of a
sudden you have to side with him and
like protect beauty and it I love grand
Budapest hotel because I think it's
everything he's been trying to make his
entire career and now I get why he does
the films he does I still don't get
marvelous I think it might pick out some
technical wins though I think me because
it looks yeah I mean I think that's
where I might pick up some women I think
it could do team play I'm for me the
biggest disappointment of this of the
Best Actor category is refined isn't up
there I think that's the performance of
the year yeah he is hilarious and it's
something that we've never seen from him
before isn't it was interesting it's
such a tricky character okay thank you
so much we will come back to you for
your opinions on the rest of the film's
later
so one of the most talked-about films
this awards season has been a Martin
Luther King biopic Selma but perhaps
more so for its lack of nominations the
Academy's failure to recognize the
performance of British actor david o
yellow o opened up a debate about a lack
of diversity in the film industry
director ava duvernay spoke to skies
lacuesta Barack what I do know he is
nonviolent but I need to know right now
what's Martin Luther King about to do
next it's about power of people about
the black citizens in the deep south to
put their livelihood a min lives at risk
for voting rights that we all enjoy in
the United States and so it felt wrong
to just have them talked about and not
see them it felt wrong to have King on
and on a pedestal and not show the other
leaders of the movement who did amazing
amazing deeply rooted work so it felt
wrong to not have women of the movement
included in it in a very you know robust
and meaningful way so these are all
things that I was concerned with and
luckily as the director I get to make a
decision about what's in and what's out
and and I'm glad that we you know were
able to take a more comprehensive
approach to this really pivotal time in
history to nominations fantastic
nominations but people have said you
deserved more I think it's what we've
got people think we deserve more I mean
it doesn't really bother me as a like it
bothers everyone else it really doesn't
I wasn't expecting anything for myself
you know I think David gave I don't
think I know that David a yellow gave
one of the best performances of the year
I think it's really too bad and that
he's not included as one of the five
that are amplified to the Oscars but it
takes nothing away from the work that a
bit not one thing but so we were
nominated in some categories and we
weren't in others do you think the
reason for all this is slightly deeper
in terms of what is going on with
diversity when the earth within the
Oscars I mean the problem is systemic
you know it's not about one thumb I mean
my question would be why was some of the
only thing
only with people of color that was even
in the running that's a problem that's
the problem that there was only one and
when that one didn't make it that there
was nothing else there on the landscape
to kind of you know diversify cinematic
image of you know that what's supposed
to be excellence in the cinema cinematic
image for the year that is really
disconcerting so how do you solve it
them there needs to be opening up of
this industry that needs to be opening
up of of gaze of voice you know we
cannot you know kind of batten down the
hatches around one singular type of
filmmaker one singular type of story you
know the the films that are nominated
the directors that are nominated the
performances are nominated our lovely
artistic expression this artistic
expression of one point of view and one
kind of life the life of mostly white
men and so women need to be in the mix
as filmmakers as storytellers as the
centers of their own story people of
color must be in the mix in the same way
and until that happens then you keep
having these conversations that are
really very surface around one film that
doesn't make it around one year we get
distracted by that when that's so not
the point the point is that this is a
systemic issue it's industry-wide its
decades-old and I hope that my prayer is
that this talk around Selma and
inclusion and exclusion and
representation and adversity really
triggers true change and not just sound
bites some of Britain's finest on the
screen talons are in the Oscars race but
it's behind the scenes where we're
really thriving with a raft of
nominations it's a golden year for the
best of British behind the
headline-grabbing on the screen talent
of this year's Oscar nominees there are
hundreds of people excelling in
technical brilliance visual effects hair
and makeup music and production design
often taken for granted but vital to the
movie making
yes we used to look up in the sky and
wonder at our place in the stars Paul
Franklin has already won an Oscar and
he's been nominated again for the visual
effects he produced for christopher
nolan's interstellar any movie is a
collaboration of all sorts of different
skills and talent and in the case of
interstellar visual effects is very much
part of that process is at the heart of
the storytelling and I think we created
some very unusual imagery we did we work
very very hard to give everything a
level of reality and believability in
what is really quite a fantastic story
film is not just about what we see it's
also about what we hear with the
soundtrack of a movie another tool in
telling the story Gary yo sean has been
recognized for his score on Mike Leigh's
mr Turner mr. Tallis seems to have taken
leave of formed
our silence is in our choice not to use
music was a significant as it as
important as considered as when we use
me as it can like liberated space for
the music to have a quite powerful
impact which i think is how it got
recognized and listen to take your hands
off my lobby boy
where's anderson's the grand budapest
hotel tops the list of nominated films
with a total of nine Oscars the cast
hair and makeup were an essential part
of creating his hyper-stylized look
Gustav who's this one he only loves
women that are blonde hence we wanted
reef to have a slightly gold tinged his
hair and that was down to Frances Hannon
my feeling on film whatever you're doing
is less is more if you're distracted by
it then there's something not quite
right it isn't sitting well but if it's
invisible but there's still gives a
feeling of the period or the character
or whatever is you're trying to portray
then you've got it right the skills
however Britain boasts are far from
invisible and that talent combined with
attractive tax breaks means more movies
than ever are being based here coming up
Oscar's on a shoestring the British
filmmaker hitting the big time on a
budget and we'll have a guided tour of
the hottest red carpet in the world
it's been said that success that the
Oscars has almost as much to do with a
film's campaign as the quality of the
work with studio spending millions in
the run-up to the ceremony but some
young British film makers have earned
nominations for their short films on a
more modest budgets including director
Michael Lennox who's been nominated for
his short boogaloo and Graham we've got
news where I'm we've got news for you
too oh yeah me and James are gonna be
vegetarians from Niall except for
sausages look yeah it's a trusted I'm
burgers as well sausages and burgers i
watch christmas we don't want a turkey
we wanna was it energy market I'm not
roost I we will not roast you want a nut
ruse for Christmas is that already in
love
and Michael joins me now Michael lovely
to see and congratulations on your
nomination well thank you very much what
was it like that moment where you found
out that you had to be nominated it's
completely surreal we do know you make
films and you make jokes the remains are
some day we'll be at the Oscars on all
of a sudden no its reality because first
of all you get an email from the Oscars
and you think it's junk mail you think
someone's playing this practical sick
joke on you and then you're sort of
googling known as a strudel and it was
true and we're just sitting there going
this is this is this is pretty amazing
we're here in Hollywood there are so
many big budget movie so many big budget
campaigns what's it like working with
not very much money and no campaign
behind you well it's um it's a lot of
fun because you have to think and be you
know creative to know how can we you
know promote the film you know slightly
differently so we've tried to use online
social networking with made sort of
numerous videos to try and to know
promote you know promote the phone
because you can't compete with 30
million they spent 30 million quid on a
movie we'd love 30 million quid to make
a movie and I expand on PR don't know
it's a pretty amazing but it's a pretty
amazing world over here just to see how
do you know what all works I'm for us to
have our small Belfast chicken movie
plan at the academy theater the other
day we're just sitting there pinching
ourselves going when are they going to
kick his eyes so you've won the BAFTA
how confident are you feeling about
about that Oscar to be honest not to be
not to be Bell fastened invaders were
sort of like we didn't think would win
the BAFTA we thought they would go for
more serious you know stuff but it's
sort of nor do they seem that you know
like our film and but I think we're I
think we're up I think we've got a good
shot I think you'll be I think I can
have a wee bit of la positivity and go
we've got a good shot but there's so
many great films you know part of the
category they're just happy to be there
have I written speech not yet I'm taking
my sister to go to the Oscars so it's a
sort of special it's a sort of special
moment you know for us do not mean that
I can sum I bring my family in and you
know the whole experience so I think
that's what makes it yuge the exciting
for us and the votans close there's
nothing we can do
we can just have a good an absolutely
bangin time and we'll have to try and
convince people to let us into the
Vanity Fair party apparently you need an
Oscar to get in easily short apparently
will have the arriving with that sir
that's her ticket or else we'll have to
get try and black her way in well when
you've won the Oscar and you go to find
it about we will speak to you on Sky
sunrise thank you so much no no thank
you so much thank you so much so it's
obviously Michaels first time on the
Oscar red carpet so what can he expect
his Joe with a sneak peak so for 51
weeks of the year this is a normal
Street in West Hollywood but for one
week only is transformed into the center
of the world of entertainment now the
celebrities come through that door
behind me and they're very quickly
ushered into place because you see even
celebrities have VIP status this is the
VVIP Lane this is where they speak to
the world's media then here in the
middle is usually a fast lanes then go
straight into the dolby theatre
sometimes people like Brad Pitt last
year took the fast lane didn't speak to
the press didn't go see the fans either
and here on the other side is the other
nominees and guess who can just meander
their way down and you know they're like
us they want to see what Julianne Moore
is wearing and all that kind of thing
so a little short wall can you get to
score a spot it within the press and as
you can see there's basically press from
all around the world here and you're
very very lucky believe me you don't
just get to sit on like this you get
sort of half a bunchy can you sort of
angle your way in and get your spot for
about four hours while you wait and see
if I'm Hall Pass
and it's not just the press that here
either it's also the fans they sit on
the bleachers their competition winners
they sit there they have to get in at
about eleven o'clock in the morning it's
such a long wait hours and hours they
even get a little pack lunch provided by
the Academy and usually Wolfgang Puck
the famous chef of course frozen a
couple of chocolate Oscars as well
finally as they make their way down the
carpet usually it takes about an hour
it's not as quick as we've just done it
they get themselves the dolby theatre
where the actual ceremony takes place on
sunday evening and hopefully someone
Eddie Redmayne we hope of course a Brit
we're picking up a smaller version of
one of those guys and Joe joins me now
along with amy nicholson from LA Weekly
to discuss the final Best Picture
nominations but first let's take a look
at them I got a military-age male us on
a cell phone watching the cowboy over if
you think he's reporting troop movement
you have a green light your call mr.
president dr. King is here the south
there have been thousands of racially
motivated murders we need your help dr.
Candace things just gonna have to wait
it cannot wait you're hurt there you are
God
what about you how was your week you do
hang out with you have a girlfriend what
have you been up to I see your point Amy
first of all american sniper so this has
been the biggest box-office hit of all
of them hasn't it especially here in the
States very very popular could it be a
dark horse or best picture you know if
you had said that to me two months ago I
would have thought no way that's
impossible but I do think the Academy is
prone to wanting to reward things that
they think have a cultural impact and
money speaks for a huge cultural impact
I think I'm American sniper is a pretty
terrible film and I'm just at this point
I'm crossing my fingers and hoping it
does not get that win I think it would
be a travesty if it gets that way I mean
it's the most black and white betrayal
of the Iraq war I mean whatever your
political persuasions it's a wall that
divided millions and you can't have this
Americans good Iraqis bad sort of mantra
going through to our movies it's a
horrible films jingoistic is some sort
of recruitment video for the US military
on this girl I'm all right yes I think
it first of all it's it's a biopic is
based on a true story is based on an
American steel and it is one point of
view even if you don't agree with it the
problem with super is even technically
it's a movie called American slipper and
there's not even that much sniping
clinics with like oh let's take him door
to door I really did it's a bungled
movie I've ever level in many respects
and I think the fact that it's so black
white makes it done you need a bit of
gray in there I mean it think it's a
lazy piece of filmmaking even clean easy
easy Wow Joe that's really hard okay
Selma so this story about Elmer has been
all about the snubs yes it hasn't been
nominated I think the biggest snub with
Selma is the fan of David a yellow
hasn't got a nod for Best Actor I mean
the fact that the fact that he's there
Bradley Cooper is there and David a
yellow isn't a thing it's a travesty did
you enjoy it I agree i think it's a very
handsome fun i didn't i didn't love it
as much as a lot of other people did so
i can't say i'm crying too many tears
for it but it does really odd that you
know Ava Duvernay didn't get any
nominations that they're saying oh it's
best picture but it's not best at
anything else again one was on it that's
think that's very unusual out Birdman I
have to say this is not one that I
massively enjoyed but it does seem to be
the one to beat for Best Actor for best
picture and the best director well right
well here's the thing with the Academy
is they would like to make they like to
give a worse to a few types of movies
one of them is biopic
yeah the other one is movies that make
it look like moviemaking and Hollywood
and creativity are like incredibly hard
noble profession and that's how you get
wins like Argo and the artist
Shakespeare in Love I mean this is the
sort of movie that they love it acts as
maybe its vocal Academy is made up from
actors mean I mean I thought was like a
pretentious twaddle you know there you
go yeah exactly what it makes what they
do seem like the hardest job on the
planet you know to which I wish plumbers
can be like come on what are you talking
about i mean i think there's a shout for
it getting best directors I mean I think
the one take kind of effect it is enough
in is a unique but I mean really that
should go to Richard Linklater and boy
had a good challenge that he's overcome
a final picture is his boyhood for me I
think this has to get best picture
Richard Linklater is absolutely
brilliant not only is his vision
fantastic but he also for me execute it
brilliantly but I know Joe you don't you
don't agree well I didn't hate it I
found it very difficult I found it
difficult to get into I can find it
difficult to get it almost because I
mean I found it pretty dull in my own
believe that you're not saying I can't
let you get away with it I think I think
it's beautiful there we go don't believe
that I work I feel like it's kind of
like it's almost like a gimmick it's a
very impressive gimmick that they spent
12 years making this move and they all
came back once a year and you watch your
boy grow up but I think it's almost like
a documentary I think if it had been if
the story had happened without that
gimmick it would be the world's dullest
movie and he couldn't have predicted it
but he picked up a lead who's not that
interesting and the older he gets in the
more the movie is about him the more I
lost interest I wish this movie had been
about Richard Linklater's daughter who
shows up early on in the film that kind
of gets pushed to the side are like she
is interesting that movie I would be all
about that one well thank you both so
much for joining me you agreed for too
much on all of that but that was
brilliant i believe that's all from
hollywood for now remember we'll be
bringing you all the buzz live from the
red carpet and will be grabbing the
winners at the Vanity Fair after party
on Sky News on Monday morning see you
then
ariella sponsors the Oscars on Sky the
home of red carpet fashion